You try to preserve a fleeting moments
well,
depends what you call bleeding.
Sometimes a geologic sense,
the years of a pretty woman and
sometimes with the people,
the 25th of a second
these days,
you're most likely to see the work of
American photographer,
ansell Adams on a postcard or on the
wall of your boss's office.
His photographs are so ubiquitous now
that it's easy to walk by them without
noticing their technical anesthetic
mastery.
Indeed,
thanks to things like instagram and
snapchat,
photographs in general are so ever
present in our lives that standards
about what we believe to be great work
in this field are drowned out by the
literally billions of photos that are
uploaded to the services.
Every day I come across something that
excites me.
I see the picture in my mind is high and
I make the photograph and then I give it
to you as the equivalent of help.
In the beginning,
ansell Adams took photographs.
Not unlike all those millions of us on
instagram as a visual diary of his
experience,
Adams took his first Brownie box camera
on trips to the Sierra Nevada mountains
to place that wouldn't throw him for the
rest of his life.
His early photographs are enthusiastic,
but uninspired.
Adam had that feeling that I have every
single time I pick up a still camera of
not getting in the print.
What I see with my eyes.
Now,
this is largely because of the dynamic
range of the human eye.
The brightest and darkest thing it can
see at the same time exceeds any film or
Digital Camera,
especially those answers was using in
the early 20th century,
but this all changed friends on April
10th,
19,
27.
The footage you're watching right now is
from an excursion.
Adams took with his future wife,
Virginia,
to the half dome in Yosemite National
Park,
holding his corona view camera,
two lenses to filters,
a heavy wouldn't tripod and 12 class
plates.
He made his way onto the so-called
diving board where you can look along
the side of the massive granite dome.
And here Adams had a vision of what he
wanted his image to look like.
He cites this as his first conscious use
of the technique called visualization,
the whole key live specifically in
seeing it to the mind's eye,
which we call it visualization.
First,
Adam's tried his yellow filter.
This is the image it produced similar
probably to what Adam saw looking
through the camera's viewfinder,
but it's not what he visualized in his
mind's eye.
There was no excitement in the frame,
so he took out his red filter for a
second shot.
He said the exposure at [inaudible] and
expose the plate for five seconds.
When Adam's developed this photo and it
his internal visualization,
he knew that this was his life's
calling,
and look at the difference,
it makes the darkened sky charges the
image with drama and intensity in
contrast,
and Adams had an instinctive genius
about tonal balance.
In contrast,
and to formalize this craft to ensure
that he could achieve his
visualizations.
He developed another tool with his
friend Fred Archer called the zone
system.
The zone system splits the full range of
black to white into 11 separate zones,
each one f stop or aperture setting
apart.
The photographer spot meter is different
elements in his frame and determines
where everything fits in the zones.
This way,
the photographer has a sense of what his
entire frame will look like before he
shoots knowing how everything will
change with different exposures.
To take a look at Adam's famous photo of
the tetons and the snake river taken in
1942.
The contrast here is really incredible
and to get a better sense of it.
Let's pixelate the image.
Look how Adams represents basically
every zone in the system all the way
from zone zero,
full black in the shadow of the
mountains here to zone 10 in the light
reflecting off the river.
What's even more extraordinary is his
ability to capture the highlight detail
in the clouds and elsewhere on the river
and the shadow details and the trees
that covered the bank.
Perhaps music is the most expressive.
However,
as a photographer,
I believe that a photography practice in
terms of quality may also reveal endless
horizons,
meaning
ansell Adams work,
his devotion to craft and more
importantly,
intention in photography is an important
example in our time when there are more
pictures posted in six months than there
are stars in the Milky Way Galaxy.
Having fought so hard for the acceptance
of photography as an art,
Adams probably would've laughed at a
statistic like that today.
Everyone has a camera,
but how many visualize what they're
going to capture beforehand?
How many measure the light or hike for a
day to reach the perfect spot so the
next time you walk by one of Ansell
Adams photographs in the hallway of your
doctor's office,
take a longer look and remember that our
photographic world is the one he gave
us.
Anything that excites me is that within
not too many years,
we're going to have a title,
a new medium of expression that they hit
me and I know the potentials are there.
I don't want to be wonderful.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I love insulate them.
Such a good hearted person and a great
artist and I had so much fun making
this,
a lot of cool things that I was
experimenting with here,
which is what I love to do.
I just love to experiment with editing
and try to give you something that I
hope you haven't seen before on Youtube.
Um,
so if you want to help support this
channel,
you can go right here and go to my
patrion page,
pledge a dollar or $3 per video.
Everything helps.
You guys have been amazing and I will
see you guys next Wednesday for
something new.
I'm excited.